Ken Alto. Do you want to introduce yourself and what you do?
Yes. Nice to meet you. My name is Ken natto. I am a CUNY mater in Japan, uh,
since, uh, 2015.
And so I'm head walk on the projects. Layer. Dragon was super brewery.
My hero academia Juju. A lot of things. Yes. And, uh.
Okay. Sorry. I just love idea.
And I am a anemic actually animator at [inaudible].
Oh, okay. Wow. Well, we have a quick spread of some of the shows you worked,
so not everything. Wow. You work at monsters university.
I like pretty much are shown in germs. So yeah.
Yeah. I mean, obviously this is an older shows that kids worked on,
but you know, this, these are the, probably I'd say the most notable ones.
I mean, there's obviously more like, uh, you know,
the recent Jews of Kaizen as well, right?
16. Oh, that would be Friday and recently also a Kimmy's tonight. [inaudible].
Oh my God. Oh my God. You actually drop that. That's one hell of a CV. Well,
thank you very much for coming on because it's nice to have someone who's
actually been working in the industry and is knowledgeable about what it's
actually like working in there.
So I've just having three guys sitting in the room, just, just taking guesses,
taking pot shots, like, you know,
knowledgeable guests or sometimes not knowledgeable guests.
I think when we don't have a guest, it's like, don't listen to what we say.
We don't know. We're talking about literally like firsthand,
like source right now.
Now we can get the answers at the same time as our audience.
I am curious if there was perhaps one scene or one show that you would recommend
for someone to watch to maybe experience your work the best. What would you.
Actuary? Or we maybe say Andre,
I'm walking in a movie foster to foresee. I can say the name,
not them. Uh, actually, yeah, I,
on this movie I put all my goods. So, uh, yes,
you have to wait a bit, but uh, yeah. Uh, yeah.
Quick way to promote the new moon.
My best one is one that you're going to have to [inaudible].
Yeah. [inaudible] I think it's a good shot I have done. So.
I mean, how long have you been working in the industry.
Now? Uh, so we, we don't count my internship.
It will be now five years. And so I start as an in-betweener and so to
clean up the in-betweens and I have done just for one in
half and after I failed the have switcher of statue,
I went to [inaudible] and the previous teacher was a graphic guy and,
uh, [inaudible] made a,
so a two year and half and now I am
a studio foresee.
Let's see if we'll see.
Cause like it's it's because your background is that your half Japanese,
half French. Right? So it was like,
what made you want to start working in the anime industry? Actuary in.
France, we have the, uh, the first-run first-generation in the nineties and, um,
uh, show Crow, quarter cup Doughty. And I actually adore it.
It was a woman who bought a lot of anime and dragon board since
CR Ms when we cocoon run ma. And so when I was little,
I watched those shows and also I want often to
Japan with my mother and yeah,
I was used to watch a lot of animals when I was kid and I grew with
mangelwurzel and so, yeah,
I used to draw those characters when I was a liter.
And so I w at first I wanted to be a manga.
As does everyone. I think every, every, I think every weep has had that dream.
Once I'm in their lives, it's like, who's like,
who draws their first name to make characters? Like, yeah,
I'm on my way to be on. Let's go.
Why are you telling me that you've never had like a,
like a story or something that you've just like, fantasized about? No, never.
You never fantasized as a kid at all. Probably. But I finally, it was like,
that was like my thing. Right. I'm sharing it with other people sharing.
When you never had a phase where you were like, I guess,
like you started watching animated, like a little bit of like,
that's true in 16. I started watching it pretty late.
I think I probably didn't get that whimsical phase of, yeah, because I mean,
how old were you when you like first? Like really,
I guess like while knowing that this is.
Anime. Oh, wait, I don't remember. I sing, I sing as a shock. I had,
it was in 98 when I watch a princess monarchy.
Uh, and for the same, uh, we didn't know what I'm watching,
but it was beautiful.
And I was just a nine, nine, nine, nine.
And also when I, uh, watch Evangelian, I was just 10 or 11.
How good did you understand anything? Oh, Hey, St. Mere actually saved me.
I'm glad somebody.
I was understanding everything, but all is make out just early and okay.
That's, that's all you like understand about Ava when you're like, yeah. Right.
It's like good guys, bad guys.
I watched it last year and that's pretty much my understand.
Yeah. I, um, the characters' was 14 and the story and I was 11.
So close enough.
Yeah. True. True. It's going to be me.
I actually have a similar story about like Ava.
Cause Ava is the second proper anime that I watch after discovering it was
anime. So the first,
the first anime I've ever watched knowing it was an anime was narrative.
And how I found that was I was on a random gaming forum. And you know,
it was back when having animate avatars was actually cool.
And I was like, Oh, well, what are these that people have?
They look really cool. And I found that one and one guy had this avatar.
That was the show from the show called narrow toe. And I'm like, Oh,
this kind of looks like dragon ball, Z watch narrative. I loved it.
Introduced me to anime properly. Um,
and then I went on the same game for him and I made it like an anime thread.
I was like, guys, this narrative is awesome.
Can you guys recommend me something else to watch like narrative?
And some guy deadass goes,
you should watch evangelical totally like narrative.
So I went to Yvonne galleon. I was like an 11,
12 year old thinking he was a shown anatomy.
And so for like the first, I'd say half of it,
it could like maybe have like past as I've shown him because you
know, Shinji, you could have still, you know, Shinji was still doing stuff.
And then the halfway point here, and then everyone just got sad. I'm depressed.
And I, my 11 year old mind was just like, why, why are people like this?
This is, this is so stupid. This is so unrealistic.
I remember thinking as an 11 year old,
this is the sh the writing of the show is so bad because the adults don't have
their together. Why is that? So why don't the adults have their together?
This is so unrealistic.
I'm like 11 year old guy coming up to his mom being like mother,
what is depression in this show called Eve and Gilliam.
And now I'm just like, Oh yeah. So adults just,
no adults just have their together. That's just life.